another ccsd board meeting lasting well
into the night as trustees talk about
two contentious issues the first to
possibly reconsider the recent firing of
dr jesus jarrah the second is related to
claims of a hostile work environment
this is of course impacting by the
superintendent's attorneys sasha loftis
has been at the meeting throughout the
night he joins us now live with the
latest
denise and brian tonight's meeting is
still going on as we speak but trustees
did just vote 4-3 to hire an outside
expert to assess that claim of a hostile
work environment throughout the district
now again one of two significant agenda
items
on tap for tonight the other issue
many have talked about is the discussion
to reconsider dr jarrar's october
termination trustees are talking about
this right now and hearing public
comments before a vote before the motion
was passed now before the motion rather
was to
to select an outside expert to
investigate those hostile work
environment claims trustees share their
thoughts on either side of this issue
we have access to more information than
the public and pushing these issues
under the rug
versus facing them head-on is the exact
reason why this board continues to
function like this this is going to go
far beyond a hundred thousand dollars
and is going to be so divisive
that anything that we might attempt to
do in the future to come together is
going to be absolutely impossible
that hundred thousand dollars you heard
president cavazos mention is in regards
to the cap of how much this whole
process is set to cost there were also
quite a few disruptions in the audience
tonight with at least one person being
escorted out by security though trustees
remained mostly civil again at last
check back out here live trustees were
still discussing that second agenda item
as to whether that discussion will
continue to maybe reconsider the
termination of superintendent dr
jarrah's contract this is set to last
for a while longer so make sure to stay
with 8 news now online and of course
starting at 4 a.m on air reporting live
tonight sasha loftis live local now